[Music]
some of you may remember that about two
years ago I interviewed a secular
atheist in Iraq by the name of Lubner
Achmed Lubin it reached out to us and
asked to come on the Rubin report to
share her personal story of being a free
thinker living in an unstable closed
society before our formal interview I
Skyped with Lumina privately to check
out her story and then went to my friend
former guest and Iraqi refugee himself
faisal saeed al Matar to ask him if he
felt that putting lube 'no on the show
was a good idea my fear obviously was
that we could end up putting lube in his
life at risk of course I didn't want to
bring harm to her or anyone that she
knew for simply speaking her truth as a
non-believer in an Islamic society
faisal who himself had lived under
Saddam and lost loved ones under his
brutal regime told me that if I wouldn't
talk to Lube 'no publicly that nobody
would he told me that voices like hers
are the exact type of people who suffer
most under theocratic regimes reasoning
that if as an adult she was willing to
take the risk of putting her name and
face out there i should offer her the
opportunity i really struggled with the
decision for a couple weeks and
ultimately took faizal's advice and
interviewed Lubner what you're gonna see
today is the original interview we did
with Lube 'no exactly as it aired two
years ago shortly after the interview
was released luna and her family were
subjected to death threats from Shia
militias had to go into hiding and were
forced to take various other precautions
in order to protect their safety at Lube
News request we immediately took down
the video and we didn't comment publicly
any further as not to inflame the
situation over the past two years though
several people who were viewers of the
Rubin report were able to contact Luba
privately and helped her to receive
assistance and guidance in the midst of
this horrific ordeal I also contacted
several former guests of the Rubin
report who I hoped could use some of
their connections to help lube nough and
many people did just that Lubner was
moved to a safe house at one point some
connections tried to get her to the
Kurdish controlled portion of Iraq and
others donated time and money I give
them all a shout out here but I'm not
sure that any of them even want public
accolades for their effort
I am beyond thrilled today to tell you
that over the past few months Lubner has
actually made it to the United States
and now lives only a few hours away from
me we are reposting this long-lost video
so that you can see our original chat as
a prelude to Lubner joining me right
here in studio which we will post next
Monday
hopefully Lunas journey will be an
inspiration not only to all of the
people across the world who live in
closed societies so that they can
realize that they aren't alone but also
for all the people who live in open
societies but have forgotten just how
truly special
that is alright I'm really excited about
what we're doing today I am here with
Luna Achmed she is a human rights
activist in Iraq and we connected a
couple weeks ago first on Twitter and
Facebook and now we've exchanged a
couple emails
Luga it's a pleasure to actually see you
well thank you it's my pleasure to meet
you I'm very excited about the interview
and I only want to make something you
know in my life and get my voice to
reach other people who lives in closed
societies like Rock and you know Backus
town Afghanistan everywhere so I hope
you know I do good so thank you so much
for having me well the thanks is all
coming from this side but all right so
there's so much I want to talk to you
about first off I guess most importantly
so you're in Iraq right now you're 25
years old is that right no 23 23 sorry
didn't mean to age you there so you're
23 years old you're in Iraq so you grew
up under Saddam Hussein and the bath
party yeah so let's just talk let's talk
a little bit about your history first
from what you can remember I know it was
a long time ago already but what was it
like growing up in that situation and
then we'll get to where we are now it
was like I said was difficult loving you
know under Saddam Hussein time and
my mother she was forced to join his
party but she refused to join in and
thus he you know his people transferred
her to another company and you know
lower salary and that went so bad you
know to me and my my my siblings as well
so it was really hard seeing a lot of
things going on you know a lot of rights
were taken from the people and the women
were suffered a lot during that time and
you know you know I saw a lot of
backboard things going on and especially
you know for the women wearing had this
carve a lot and you know calling for
rights were forbidden at that time so it
was dark
yes you know yeah can you tell me a
little bit more just a little bit about
your family like what kind of family you
grew up in and sort of when you became
you know a secular thinker and someone
interested in human rights and women's
rights and all that well my family from
the beginning my mother she was any
theist so the reason I'm thinking like
that because of her she raised me and my
siblings along to be free she didn't
force us to any to think anything about
you know religions or so she's a
mechanical engineer scientist and like
you know I mentioned in my story she
married to my father which he was turned
to be just like her brother and her
mother he abused my mom he used to hit
my mom and and he used to date my sister
my older sister as well so from that
point my mom tried to divorce him and
finally she got the divorce and another
turn in my life in my family's life
which you know began at that time we
were hated by my mother's family first
in the society we were and there are so
many attacks because my mom she is a
woman and she is divorced and in Middle
East being a woman and being divorced
without a man to identify the women they
will you know they will attack these
kind of women so well for me I started
to think about Islam and calm it since
you know 12 years old I started to ask
what is Islam whose Mohammed what is God
and that's why I kicked out of like two
to three schools I was forced to to you
know to attend the religion lessons in
my school just to get you know my
degrees or so and that's what I did but
in the same time I did search qur'an and
islam and i do think that i want to say
this Islam is an extreme religion
there's no need to have a Wahhabi ism
you know a principal or so is just
itself it's extreme when you read Quran
when you read hadith you will see how
you know how there is so much violence
in it yes there are a few nice verbs
sense but when he came when you come to
the whole text and crowd no it's not
it's not it's not peaceful and I do
think that Muhammed created all this you
know religion and so on so get back to
my point I continued my education and
now I'm doing my master's in chemical
engineering and my field is reactor
design which is you know very
fascinating field and I love it yeah so
there there's so much there so you grew
it so your mom was an atheist so I
assume in your house there wasn't much
religion certainly once your your
left left the house but then you're
saying you had to take religious classes
just so that you could take the other
classes that you wanted to take right
science and math and things like that
what was it like for your mom so she's
obviously a generation ahead of you she
was you know to be a to be a secular
thinker and an atheist I mean was she
opened in terms of friends and and
family it sounds like maybe family yeah
yeah she was open and that's why her
brother abused her and once she told us
one of the times he used he used to hit
her
he used to accuse my mother he and her
mother you know her father was kind of
you know a good guy he he pushed too you
know for my mom to continue her
education but her brother won one of the
times he almost you know tried to kill
my mom with a knife she mentioned that
she was open she escaped from the house
to live in dorms actually when she was a
mechanic a mechanical engineering
student and it was it was really hard
she she she faced a lot of difficulties
having a friends and well and she ended
with my what my father went and like I
said he turned out to be nothing you
know nothing and uh so let's let's flash
forward a little bit so then I guess
it's about ten years ago now a little
bit more probably there was the American
invasion of Iraq so what was that like
for you for your family were you in the
middle of the war zone well at the
beginning we weren't very happy because
Saddam Husein was the dictator and as
you know as you know a lot of people
know about Saddam Husein and what he did
to the Iraqi people we weren't very
happy at the beginning to be honest but
then it turned out it's not it's not the
same I mean we lost a lot of I think
rights back to Saddam Husein time
as women they you know they used to walk
down the streets in the middle of the
night safe but now after the invasion no
we didn't see that a lot of rights were
lost a lot of things are going on and
especially right now
and you know it's after the invasion a
lot of Shia militia took over the the
country so was was really bad and it is
really bad because there is no central
government tuner option no more and I
think I suppose that the Iraqi
government is ruled by Iran I do really
think that so for me and my family
facing all these things was really
difficult and we got a lot of threats
but as you see I am still alive so as my
family and well I was continuing so yes
well that's why that's why we're doing
this and I think you're incredibly
inspiring and I had said to you before
before we started I had said to you you
know I don't want to do anything that
would jeopardize your safety and
basically I don't have to say it for you
but you you could say what you said to
me about that it's okay I think because
I do believe in myself to the ultimate
point that you know I give it all
because it's time to talk terrorists
have the right to exist in Iraq you know
a religious religious man that
pretending you know Islam have the right
everyone you know has their eye except
the people who don't believe in God or
who don't believe in religions it
actually religions I do I kind of you
know define religion as anything that
limit the human beings are going from
thinking freely from being creative
because religious you know do you put
these limits for us to be who we are
so
you know I refuse all these things and I
will not submit to anything at all and
this is this is the reason I'm doing
this and this is the reason you know I
want my voice to reach out others to
start to stand up because we are lost
it's time to be for us to be found and I
do wish people listened to me
yes yeah well listen I I know we're
we're literally something like 8,000 or
10,000 miles apart but I can feel it I
can actually feel that connection
through this this Skype thing so it's
really incredible so I want to hear a
little bit more about your story though
so so there you were hopeful in the
invasion happened then the invasion
happened and America was there for a
while and it seemed like things were
getting better right there were
elections there is a sense that things
were getting better so can you talk
about what what that little period was
like and then when America left did it
immediately get worse where it is now or
was it kind of a slow progression well
well like you said like you mentioned
yes it was good to have the elections
and was good to have some rights
especially for the women they were more
active in the public life and as well
for the children you know and a lot of
things were you know we're very very
good at the beginning and but with time
a lot of things you know eliminated and
for the women for the children and and
for the society yes we do have now
internet and connections to the other
world which Saddam Husein
you know at you know in his time were
prevented you know we are we were
prevented doing these things but like I
said a lot of things you know turned out
to be bad and now
Malaysia's Shia militias are taking over
the government adjacent Mahdi Rossella
salam hezid nusra to allah that he
started to you know to establish there
institutions and they do have now
buildings institutions under the eye you
know under the protection of the Iraqi
government so what I'm saying is the the
militias you know started to take a lot
of areas and Baghdad they killed a lot
of people and as you as you know from
the beginning suddenly I began to suffer
from the elimination in the government
they didn't they don't have the right to
exist in Iraq from blankey Christians
and Christian people left Iraq you know
after the invasion a lot of them left
the country which is very bad a lot of
church in Baghdad I have seen this in my
own eyes the the Iraqis Muslims turn
these truths into like you know trade
like malls and stuff like that and I did
you know take pictures of such these
things but after the US forces left Rock
well it turned out to be more worse than
this yeah now yes now Iran to cover a
lot of cities I do think and I do I'm
sure you know I have people talking to
me in south of Iraq they can see members
of the Iranian militias or you know Alka
this army and you know exist and turned
out like I said to be more worse now
even the cost the Iraqi Constitution
they put a new law for the women to
eliminate you know their rights and it
was bad and even the United Nations
you know they mentioned that but no one
you know in Iraq know and listens to
what is going on so I think you know you
got my point
no it's smaller Wars than ever yes so
what's what's it like actually for you
as a woman just on a day-to-day basis
obviously you're not wearing a head
covering right now I assume you're at
home you don't tell me where you are but
what what is your life you know going to
school work wherever it is that you go
from from morning tonight what's your
day like okay well like I said I'm
student so when I go out without a head
scarp and chart there and you know and
the way I look they pay attention to me
and a lot of attacks you know accuses I
have phased do you know I'm from high
school till this day I was physically
you know harassed and it was a difficult
time but but you know now even their
children now they they teach their
children to criticize me anyway um you
know I go on this street with you know
how I look and I got a lot like I said
Oh abuses but for me you know I fight
back I apply I do not check my mouth and
because there is no reason for anyone to
criticize anyone there is no right for
anyone to you have the right to oblige
others to follow their way you know what
I mean each one of us is free to do
whatever they want so for me you know I
do whatever I want I don't care because
I'm not affecting anyone without with
you know I'm doing so that's for me yeah
so I'm curious how other women react to
you because obviously they're not all as
brave as you are and are going out and
talking about the things you're talking
about and and publicly saying the things
that you're saying and even just going
out without the head are they talking to
you privately
yeah well that the woman are the first
one who attacks me to be honest really I
do
yeah I do have a lot of males you know
they were a you know agreement to my
points but the woman they were attacks
me all the time and you know I don't
care about them and I try to explain how
I think can I try to reach to them but
actually they do not believe in
themselves and actually you know I
joined some of the women local
organizations Karan calling for the
women rights in Iraq and I got shocked
seeing the woman you know under the the
role of this local organization herself
is wearing hijab headscarf and for me I
don't want to look like you know
aggressive in my opinions but once you
put this piece of clothes you know you
are a slave for me I do consider these
women are slaves because it's a human
you know nature to you know for women to
have their hair to look like the men and
it's from the beginning of the you know
of the humanity it's like that and it
was mentioned I want to mention this and
cron and cron it had years the headscarf
was mentioned only for the the women of
the Prophet Mohammed let or not all the
Muslim women you know what I mean and
and in history when when you know when
you follow up and Quran and hadith in
history men were you know wearing had is
carved as well because the nature of the
deserts you know and storms they were
you know used to wear this piece of
clothes to protect them from the Sun
from the the dust so for me I faced a
lot of women attacking me but what I
said
I'm standing for myself and that's what
I'm doing
yes yeah so I know that we also we have
many things
I think in common in a lot of the people
that we both admire and I know that
you're a big admirer of Richard Dawkins
and sam Harris all of all of these free
thinkers and secular people I'm curious
how you got interested in them where it
was this just from being online were you
able to get their books or how did that
happen well my mother because she used
to you know follow them buying their
books because she has a friend you know
for he used to bring books like that you
know in secret because it's you know to
have these books in English it's it's
not isolated to Arabic which you know I
do not trust the translations to be
honest so yes so I knew these people
from my mother and we used to read you
know books for example God Delusion for
Richard Dawkins you know I'm very
faceted it it was a fascinating book we
used to read it with my mother discuss
things we are just like a gang you know
me and my siblings yeah my mother yeah
we're talking about these things so well
and I got interested in in Hitchens and
you know Sam Harris you know online sam
Harris but rich isn't a Dow khun's to my
mother actually yeah yeah well first off
for the record I want you to know that
I'm gonna make sure to send this video
to Sam so he will know who you are and
I'll do my best to get it to Dawkins as
well yeah well you you're a
representation of everything that they
care about everything that's right you
know that that we have to empower people
like you to change your society so I so
we only have a couple minutes left but
so what what can we do on the outside
because that one of the things that I
hear a lot of from people on the left in
my country is that we just have to let
you guys be it's none of our business to
get involved and and I feel the reverse
I feel it's important to talk to people
like you because you're you're a
minority within a minority
want to help your boys spread so for all
the people watching this what can we do
to help you and get these ideas out
there well the thing that you can help
is learning or reading about Islam
because Islam is the only religion now
acting so I think it's so violence in in
the West in our countries a lot of
people got killed because of this
religion and a lot of women got killed
and then there were a lot of statistics
in the Middle East mentioned that so for
me and I think you have to first learn
about this budget and it started to
support people like me to listen to us
and to have your you know your ways to
reach out others how then you know this
is what I do think and it's really run
it for me
defeating Islam yeah yes yeah and by the
way I should mention that when I when
we've briefly talked before this I asked
you you know if you were interested in
trying to leave Iraq and you can repeat
what you said well I don't know I don't
know what will happen after this I'm
okay if anything will happen to me you
know I'm I'm gonna be happy because now
my voice will be like well um thinking
yeah all right well it really is a it's
a thrill and really an honor to talk to
you and you have an ally in me and
you're gonna have an ally in literally
thousands of other people that'll hear
you after this and just keep putting
your message out there and we're gonna
keep amplifying it and I hope I hope
this is just the beginning of something
great for you well thank you very much
and
um it's just I'm not a talkative person
but I just want to you know think the
people will listen to me and I
appreciate it
you know um that they just give it all
time to see you know things and what's
going on in Middle East the media is not
a free nothing is for you to be non so I
think you have to just put it give it a
little bit of your time and effort to
see things to see the reality and I hope
you understand that and thanks you for
having me
and again alright and I'm sorry okay I'm
not that talkative no sorries Thank You
Luna and we're gonna of course we're
gonna stay in touch and I'm gonna get
this to Sam
[Music]
you